des témoignages révolte à qui on fait
beaucoup réagir aujourd'hui à québec et
le reportage complet n'est même pas
encore diffusé je vous fait écouter
salle et l'entente de la ministre la
sécurité publique qui évidemment doit
prendre cette histoire très au sérieux
je vous rappelle qu'on parle de huit
policiers de la sûreté du québec dont
certains toujours un exercice à val d'or
le premier ministre chef de l'opposition
aussi on les écoute
est ce que le premier ministre confirme
qu'il s'agit d'une enquête indépendante
d'enquêter rapidement commencer par les
périodes des personnes sont dans les
corps policiers mais indépendante du
passous territoire est ce que je devrais
demander à mon collègue respectueusement
c'est de juger l'arbre à ses fruits
les enquêtes vont bientôt se conclure
elles seront transmises aux autorités
pour ce crime les pdg pauvre vue
l'entièreté du reportage mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'un policier qui
est en situation d'autorité
c'est inacceptable d'abuser de son poste
de son courant pour agresser
sexuellement des femmes - tirer profit
particulièrement lorsque les femmes sont
dans des situations de les merengues
avec moi michèle audette bonsoir michèle
audette ex président de l'association
des femmes autochtones du canada
candidat du parti libéral dans
terrebonne jeudi soir madame odette que
les policiers puissent s'ajouter à la
liste des agresseurs déjà commencé le
problème la violence faite aux femmes
autochtones c'est énorme au pays
votre première réaction à cela parce que
ça vous surprend surprendre surprend non
mais ça n'empêche pas que sam chaque pic
ça me répugne parce que c'est la même
histoire que les femmes de la
colombie-britannique où dans le nord la
haye way of kings où on dit 'de du
rapport de human rights watch
la relation entre la grc les femmes
autochtones et les dysfonctionnelle des
femmes violées
et battue menacé de mort il ya des
preuves à l'appui des photos et des
témoignages accablants et par an alors
on retrouve la même situation
ici à val d'or alors moi ce que je lance
comme message au gouvernement du québec
à cette enquête là qui tient lieu c'est
de voir au delà de val d'or qu'est ce
qui se passe sur l'ensemble du
territoire du québec je serais très
surprise parce que il ya deux choses
cette enquête d'abord la sûreté du
québec enquêter sur ses propres agents
on aurait peut-être pu demander un autre
corps policier on verra les grisailles
est le premier mise vous dit ça a été
mieux oui plus clair plus clair
transparent et on assure que ce sont des
gens de l'extérieur qui analyse parce
que il y aura peut-être des accusations
qui vont tomber très bientôt
quand on lit entre les lignes de la
ministre et du premier ministre
sauf que l'anc est plus globale comme
vous dites élites à faire là pas une
enquête théorique là sur les la vie des
autochtones une enquête sur la violence
faite aux autochtones par des
autochtones et par dénonce doute oui
l'on parle de deux choses l enquête
nationale publique où on demande que ce
soit complètement indépendante donc on
nomme des experts le fédéral les
provinces et territoires les communautés
autochtones de nommer des experts pour
faire la lumière sur tout ça mais le
québec propose actuellement une
commission parlementaire donc on
s'entend que ce sont des parlementaires
dont des élus qui vont poser des
questions alors la mécanique reste à
savoir je la connais pas encore je salue
l'exercice quand même mais disons nous
que si on change de gouvernement la
commission arrête là mais cette
commission que le québec veut mettre sur
pied c'est utile selon vous s'apprête
unis une commission itinérante aller se
promener un peu partout au québec
moi je me dis toute action comme le
reportage on vient de voir la semaine
passée avec les enfants qui de morts
violentes est situé toutes les actions
qui démonte ce qui se passe au canada et
au québec sur la question autochtone est
un plus pour nous pour démontrer qu il
faut agir pas seulement les groupes
autochtones dévoué - il reste
les gens qui nous écoutent faut agir
revenons sur ses victimes potentielles à
val-d'or vous j'imagine que vous
souhaitez que ces femmes là sortent
aussi plus librement publiquement
prennent la parole et dénonce leur
agresseur il faut dénoncer je mangeais
celui le courage de toutes ces femmes là
comme les autres femmes la semaine
passée qui parlait d'une petite fille
qui s'est enlevé la vie à onze ans
madame flamand à leur faut continuer à
protéger ces fameux les encourager à
paris mais le fait de parler ça fait
aussi bouger au sein d'une communauté ou
d'une ville
comment recevoir cette problématique là
alors que dans nos communautés peut-être
que il ya un manque frappant de services
adéquats pour répondre à cette crise
donc parler mais qu'est-ce qu'on a un
très long mais c'est sûr que si des
policiers devaient être accusé dans une
histoire comme celle-là ça vox et
malheureux tout ça mais savoir
c'est un électrochoc là surtout le
système pour les gens qui nous écoutent
oui mais pour ceux et celles qui
travaillent la dengue est habitué
d'entendre des histoires comme ça on
sait qu'il ya des policiers sauvent des
vies
on sait que des policiers ne voulaient
pas céder sur leurs importants mais ceux
qui ont posé des actes que moi j'appelle
inacceptable et criminel ne devrait plus
travailler auprès des gens comme ça chez
nos dettes on va suivre ça au cours des
prochains jours des prochaines heures
merci d'être venu nous voir et elle est
extrêmement troublant comme histoire
j'avais raison merci l'oms et messieurs
nos adresses commentaires on vous lit
avec beaucoup d'attention
vous allez les voir dans une seconde
merci